frame me he framed me now was sucked it
up yeah it was a real success for the
defense that is the big moment last
night on the People vs OJ when Robert
Kardashian realized Simpson could go
free now as you know Robert is the
father of the Kardashian kids on the
shell it's got to be so strange for them
to be watching it absolutely I mean can
you imagine can you actually imagine
because they lived this and not all of
his kids actually rushed to see this
Cameron we talked about the family when
I sat down exclusively with OJ
prosecutor Chris Darden did you meet the
Kardashians of course I met Chris back
then of course I knew Robert I recall
one day I believed it was one day when
she brought the children with her to
court they were in the DA's offices I
would call early on you know in the
trial but they were little kids those
kids Courtney Rob Khloe and Kim lived
through the celebrity trial of the
century imagine what it must have been
like their father Robert Kardashian was
OJ's confidante their mother Kris Jenner
was a good friend of Nicole Brown
Simpson who Oh J was accused of
murdering and now the case is back in
the spotlight just believe just quit the
case the Kardashian family struggle and
Roberts internal conflict are major
themes and FX's the People vs OJ Simpson
I'm so sorry
I feel like it feels like yesterday
sometimes you know because it's so some
things are still so fresh Kris and Kim
have both said they liked the show but
Kourtney didn't start watching it till
this week she posted a screen grab of
David Schwimmer as her dad and wrote
finally watching oj episode 2 this is
weird to watch it's unclear if Rob has
watched the series but Khloe appears to
be holding out I think I'm a little more
sensitive to it because he was my uncle
Oh Jay like that's always what I called
him and I hear David Schwimmer did a
phenomenal job and they play him really
true to form yeah so I'm grateful for
that but yeah it's just I don't know
it's not that I won't watch it I just
have like a little reservation time yeah
after our sit-down Darden shared
something pretty remarkable documents
and evidence from the Simpson trial
there's an image of Nicole at a police
station reporting domestic abuse and
this and never-before-seen booking card
with OJ's handprint for Darden it seems
there is no escaping the case or the
Kardashians well you know I lived across
the street from Khloe and Lamar for a
while you did yeah yeah up in Tarzana
and my son chase and I we met Lamar you
know down the street at the doughnut
shop one day the morning before Game
seven what do I think about the
Kardashians I god bless america
capitalism at its best yeah oh yeah
right